sometimes the information coming out is
good like with Harvey Weinstein was
doing right we're now Kevin Spacey like
I don't know are you here everyone knew
he gave a [ __ ] but this other stuff it's
like wolf like you hoped for his sake
that this is just some dumb isolated
thing hate you don't think so you think
I have not heard have you heard listen I
have heard [ __ ] yeah nothing like like
nothing like within my reach just
innuendo and
yeah I've heard things I've heard things
I've heard things you have heard things
nothing like first hand but just things
but it's like I always go back to
Whitney Houston because when the rumors
first came out about Whitney Houston
being being a drug addict and God bless
Whitney Houston and she had a rough life
but she was so like at the time again
this is in the in the late 80s and 90s
before social media but you were like
there's no way wouldn't use crackhead
look at she's [ __ ] beautiful like
she's clean-cut and then you know now is
I remember for years but get the [ __ ] at
it no come on Whitney Houston Whitney
and then it came out in my opinion
listen every single person every star
there's not one star who hasn't been
accused of being gay from Will Smith to
Brad Pitt to Leonardo DiCaprio to Eddie
Murphy to ever all of them for every
every single person in Hollywood has
been accused of being gay accused you
know whatever the word is after saying
lest you mention by the way every single
actor every single rock star axel road
mixer I mean everybody if you're that
big you're gay yeah
oh he's never been accused of being gay
I've heard he's been Koosman cab but I
prayed he would be like every single
person has been accused of being gay how
did we get on this so the accusation say
yeah I mean no so the Whitney used to
think so but then when it found out like
she had a severe drug problem and
obviously there's no jokes in that
because her life was tragic and the rest
of her family's life has been tragic and
her daughter not so but it's like yo
when there's when there's smoke from in
my opinion when there's smoke of regards
to these rumors around celebs nine times
out of ten there's fire and I mean the
excuse the apology we were talking about
it before that came out where he goes
like you know I don't remember this
incident and even if you're gonna give
him the benefit of a doubt and say like
okay he doesn't remember if a
fourteen-year-old says like he he had me
down on a bed and you're like yeah I
don't know maybe I
it doesn't happen once and you forget
about it you know and I mean there will
be a lot of 14 year-olds I play devil's
advocate for that but the thing about
all this [ __ ] is why don't you cool why
don't you tell your parents now once you
tell the cops why is it Twitter why is
it Twitter it's like 30 years of yaar
though outside this this kid was 30
years ago on thing I know I'm not yeah
I'm just saying like some of some of
these allegations with the Harvey
Weinstein any I'm not defending this
[ __ ] guy cuz apparently he's really
was on to rape [ __ ] yeah
but like why are you telling the head of
Amazon that Harvey Weinstein raped you
why aren't you going to the cops if
you're if you're comfortable enough
telling another person in Hollywood that
this happened you should be going
directly to the cops unless they think
that like these guys are so powerful
they got the cops in their back pocket
this isn't [ __ ] what is this game of
Thrones or what is it ray Donovan
no cops in the back pocket they just had
itíd the [ __ ] guy this little cops in
the back pocket this is it you know the
fun like you know the Jack Warner days
you know with Mary come on man I don't
know why you do like I don't know why
you go to them and not that maybe she
did go to the cops and there was nothing
they could do maybe there was only as he
said she said maybe they told her look
there's no evidence other than your word
against his and there's nothing I don't
know if she did or not but the problem
with that was that Amazon did nothing I
think I think that was what it was